Leben ist selbst unter
extremsten umweltbedingungen
hier auf der erde möglich zb in den heißen
Thermalquellen auf dem boden der tiefsee ein indiz dafür dass es auch auf unwirtlichen planeten oder monde
außerirdisches leben geben könnte jetzt hat ein forschungsteam entdeckt das wohl selbst in riesen
höhlen der antarktis ganze bislang unbekannte
Ökosysteme existieren könnten auf welche lebensformen die gefundenen dna-spuren hinweisen und warum diese entdeckung auch
außerirdisches leben wieder ein stück weiter wahrscheinlich macht jetzt den blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
In bodenproben aus den warmen höhlen unter antarktischen gletschern hatten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler schon vor einiger zeit die dna spuren von bakterien und pilzen
identifizieren können ein australisches forschungsteam hat nun darin überraschender weise auch dna spuren
von verschiedenen arten von moos
gliederfüßler fadenwürmern und algen entdeckt ein hinweis darauf dass dort pflanzen tiere ja sogar ganze
ökosysteme existieren könnten bisher
Unbekannte lebensform quasi aliens auf der erde der tatort der mount erebus
auf ross island und drei weitere vulkane in dieser region unter ihnen
existiert ein verzweigtes system von tunneln die einmal durch die heißen dämpfe der vulkane
entstanden sind die grundlage für leben an diesen orten seit tatsächlich gegeben so das forschungsteam nahe manchen
Höhlen eingängen gibt es wo licht und in den höhlen selbst kann es bis zu 25 grad warm werden eine beteiligte forscherin erzählt beispielsweise
dass man in den höhlen selbst tatsächlich ein t shirt tragen kann diese bedingungen sicherten die
energieversorgung von leben so die wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler neben dieser entdeckung sind vor allem diejenigen
gen fragmente in den proben spannend die sich einfach nicht
identifizieren lassen dies spricht nämlich für bislang unbekannte tier und pflanzenarten die in den antarktischen
riesen höhen leben oder aber
lebten denn das ist auch klar die dna spuren sind nicht unbedingt ein beweis dafür dass die lebewesen auch noch heutzutage
in den höhlen existieren doch weitere expeditionen sind in planung
Und tatsächlich auch durchaus realistisch denn nur wenige kilometer entfernt vom mount erebus liegt die größte
logistikbasis auf dem antarktischen
kontinent die mac modus station mit mehr als
1100 einwohnern zumindest, im sommer zudem vermuten die forschungsteams das auch unter den etwa 15 anderen vulkan in der antarktis
Höhlensysteme unter dem eis zu finden sein müssten doch die gilt es noch
zu finden und zu erforschen jedenfalls macht die entdeckung des australischen
forschungsteams wieder einmal auf ein neues deutlich wie wenig wir selbst von unserem heimatplaneten
Wissen auf dem wir leben wie viele orte es noch zu entdecken und zu erforschen gibt sehr wahrscheinlich
dass wir noch immer viel zu viele orte auf der erde beziehungsweise, im ganzen universum für
lebensversicherten obwohl sie leben tatsächlich zu lassen wohl genauso wie die unendlichen weiten des äußeren
sonnensystems wir haben ja schon öfter darüber berichtet forschungsteams weltweit wissen mittlerweile dass die theorie der habitablen zone überaltert ist
Und das biologische aktivität wie zb auf den sogenannten supererden durchaus möglich ja sogar
Wahrscheinlich ist denn selbst hier unter den extremsten bedingungen überhaupt auf der erde sind die zutaten für leben vorhanden genauso wie auf dem
Saturnmond enceladus der im inneren eben nicht zugefroren ist wie die raumsonde cassini gezeigt
Habe wie eigentlich vorher vermutet wurde und so belegt die aktuelle
entdeckung der australier auf ein neues dass die bausteine des lebens fast überall zusammen können kommen können und die indizien für außerirdisches leben
Werden immer mehr hier bei pixum halte ich euch speziell zum thema außerirdisches leben
Immer auf dem laufenden wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drücken wir
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
Außerirdisches leben auf der erde da geht es um spektakuläre funde in mexikanischen höhlen also nicht verpassen und draufklicken ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran